20 липня вранці журналіст
"Української правди" Роман Кравець
довго не міг усвідомити, про загибель якого Шеремета
розповідають в новинах. Те, що це саме Павло Шеремет,
його колега, хлопцю підтвердили в редакції
та попросили поїхати на місце вибуху - написати репортаж.
Роман дружив з Павлом і, каже, -
це було найскладніше завдання за усі 2 роки роботи
журналістом відділу політики  в «Укрправді».
Мене справді образило це все, що так сталося.
Все це вбивство………якесь таке дуже підле.
Так, якби заклали бомбу та вбили позаочі.
Мабуть, це якась несправедливість,
людина не могла себе захистити,
вона мені просто якось вибішує
Редакція "Укрправди" не одразу знайшла сили
на ґрунтовне розслідування вбивства колеги.
Через 3 місяці Роман зібрав волю в кулак
та написав підсумкову статтю з аналізом дій слідчих,
які розслідували вбивство.
Найцікавішими були дані реєстрів з рішенням судів,
які дозволили прослуховування.
Давали дозволи на прослуховування
трьох точок в Донецькій області,
які співпадали з дислокацією "Азова".
Чому Азов, я не знаю.
Можливо, там щось цікаве буде
і з огляду на те,
що останню ніч приходили до
Пал Георгіча "азовці",
в тому числі, Білецький.
Це також цікаво.
З того моменту, на думку Романа, правоохороці
особливих успіхів не мало. До того ж,
багато важиливих фактів зібрало не офіційне слідство,
а журналісти: з"ясували, що за машина стояла
біля будинку Шеремета напередодні вбивства та що там же
з"являвся і колишній
співробітник СБУ. Хоча про імена
власне виконавців - жІнки і чоловіка, які підклали вибухівку
та вранці підірвали її - ані слідство, ні журналісти
досі нічого не кажуть. Роман припускає -
ці люди могли бути пов'язані з АТО.
Яприпускаю, що можливо вони ідентифіковані. Просто не оголошені.
Якщо їх оголосять,
це зможе завадити слідству,
можливо, вони просто їх не затримують
Роман дуже добре пам'ятає, чому його вчив Павло Шеремет -
критично ставитися до будь-чиїх заяв
та перевіряти будь-яку інформацію.
Адже правда може бути геть іншою.
В редакції Шеремета недарма називали "Пал Гєроїчем"
і постійно повторювали його улюблене:
"Прорвемося!"
За "Рік без Пал Гєроїча" усі в редакції "Укрправди"
призвичаїлися спілкуватися без телефонів,
які прослуховуються, і бути уважними до власної безпеки.
Але це не позначилось на гостроті текстів того ж Романа.
"Нас ніхто не зупинить!" - було написано
на одному з вінків на похованні Шеремета.
І це ж - відповідь "Укрправди" й офіційному слідству,
й владі, які обіцяли суспільству
розкрити вбивство Шеремета,
але поки цього не зробили.
Тому колеги загиблого заявляють – вони перебрали на себе роботу правоохоронців.
Та обіцяють попри все - назвати імена вбивць та замовників.